of course what I'm talking about hot tub
on the plane with no hot tub on the
plane
no that was funny though I mean if I had
a hot tub on the plane
I needed at the game but uh I was good
I mean when I got back to the school
after the play I got fitting the coach
up
go to the lettuce back refresh did some
more treatment today yesterday just
continue to do treatment on my body keep
my body healthy man I got a long season
ahead of me
me but I did that game that's what I
gotta do every game so I just continue
to get treatment I mean because I'm not
lying I did play a lot of snaps yeah
Travis on the play 129 snaps as a
two-way player for Colorado today Steven
corner and 100 degree plus Heat
[Music]
I had 11 catches for 119.
one interception could have been two
interceptions
[Music]
could add two touchdowns that's my fault
though nobody else fault I mean I just
got to go back I got things to work on I
won pbu
it wasn't supposed to be a pbu should
have been uh
should have been an interception but
yeah
[Music]
that's one of the most insane secret
game performances and any
performances any player have has done in
the ocean
bro I mean I've been doing this my whole
life man it's nothing new to me
I'm just very humble thank God every day
for blessing me
with the talent I got it's a goddamn
work hard I mean if you guys didn't work
hard you'll see the results everybody
else will see them too so I just got
done work hard man 129 snaps by far the
most snaps I played in the game I mean
high school games not even that long so
I'm not gonna play that many high school
I play I think
120 remember High School game but
it wasn't hot it wasn't that hot
but I kind of got my win back I kind of
got my win again
at halftime so when I came on halftimes
it's like his first quarter again so I
was ready to keep continue to go as
y'all touchdowns and things that's my
fault
the TCU coach
Sunny Dykes talking about me playing the
whole game like I played with my first
quarter in the heat that I did in there
I mean I've been doing this my whole
life I just treat my body right
don't smoke no drink don't do no drugs
drink a lot of water I drunk a lot of
people like
Gatorade
eat
man just come my buddy
just treated my body right so I can't be
able to do what I've done
so
that's pretty much it I mean you're not
lying I went out there
lay my butt off every clay that I was on
the field
let me switch to report
Jimmy Butler was tired me I wasn't tired
I was ready to go I could have played a
whole another game the same day the next
hour
I was just ready continue to ready to
play I mean I love football man
thing I do the most
I love it I want to change anything for
it
I just love doing our damn plan I mean I
would have taught after the game I could
have went out there and played again I
know y'all see me but my little dancing
dance in the locker room
you're going on that TV 12 diet nah I
pretty much eat whatever I want
yeah see me look after the game
like I got first legs again ready to
guard them play again doing my little
dancey dance
but yeah I was having fun man I have fun
with my teammates we had a great time
out there in Texas